neues jahr neues ich nächstes jahr werde
ich nicht mehr so wie süßigkeiten essen
[Musik]
etwa die hälfte von uns machen sich
jedes jahr gute vorsätze fürs neue jahr
zu den häufigsten guten vorsätzen
gehören abnehmen mehr sport machen mit
dem rauchen aufhören und geld sparen
unser konsequentes scheitern an guten
vorsätzen ist so faszinierend dass es
von verschiedenen wissenschaftlern schon
untersucht wurde damit einer
amerikanischen studie werfen etwa ein
viertel der leute ihre guten vorsätze
schon nach einer woche über bord nach
dem halben jahr sind weniger als die
hälfte der leute noch am start und die
langfristige erfolgsraten nach zwei
jahren beträgt weniger als 20 prozent
doch selbst diejenigen die erfolgreich
ihre guten vorsätze umsetzen versuchen
es wahrscheinlich nicht zum ersten mal
forscher fanden heraus dass menschen
fünf bis sechs anläufe brauchen um sich
erfolgreich und langfristig zu ändern
ich habe mit dem rauchen aufgehört okay
das ist jetzt das sechste mal diesmal
muss es klappen grund für unser
scheitern ist unter anderem dass wir uns
unsere ziele viel zu hoch stecken in
diesem zusammenhang gibt es den begriff
falls hope zentrum
demnach haben wir eine völlig
unrealistische vorstellung davon wie
schnell und wie einfach wie unsere ziele
erreichen wäre nicht so schnell
außerdem ziehen wir aus unserem
scheitern völlig falsche schlüsse
anstatt einzusehen ist unsere ziele
völlig unrealistisch waren suchen wir
uns andere erklärungen warum es nicht
geklappt hat so lassen wir uns genau die
selben vorsätze immer wieder machen und
scheitern
ja ich wollte mehr laufen gehen aber
später meine hüfte ein bisschen ich
glaube ich habe auch einfach nicht die
richtigen schuhe
es gibt sogar studien die andeuten dass
selbstdisziplin eine erschöpft bahre
ressource ist in einem berühmten
experiment wurde einer gruppe von
teilnehmern schokokekse gegeben während
die zweite gruppe von teilnehmern
gebeten wurde
die schoko kekse vor sich auf dem tisch
stehen zu lassen und stattdessen gemüse
zu essen anschließend sollten alle
teilnehmer komplizierte geometrie rätsel
lösen
es stellte sich heraus dass die
gegen die vorher gemüse essen mussten
viel schneller aufgaben
das würde bedeuten dass die willenskraft
sich selbst ein arschtritt zu verpassen
irgendwann erschöpft ist was bei diesem
experiment nicht bedacht wurde ist dass
das gehirn natürlich viel besser mit
kurse arbeitet das hatten wir aber auch
schon mal in diesem video hier wie kann
man jetzt aber seine guten vorsätze
besser umsetzen das wichtigste ist dass
man sich kleine überschaubare aber vor
allem konkrete ziele sitzt man sollte
nicht einfach nur sagen nächstes jahr
mache ich mir sport sondern nächstes
jahr werde ich jeden zweiten montag fünf
minuten john g na gut vielleicht zehn
minuten und vielleicht auch jeden montag
außerdem kann es helfen möglichst vielen
leuten von seinen guten vorsätzen zu
erzählen um den sozialen druck zu
erhöhen habe ich dir erzählt ich kaufe
jetzt keine neuen klamotten mehr es gibt
aber auch wissenschaftlich genau das
nicht empfehlen weil sie beobachtet
haben dass allein das mitteilen ein
gefühl der errungenschaft auslösen kann
es auch mal ein teil der aufgabe damit
schon erledigt hätte das kann zur folge
haben dass weniger motivation zum
durchführen der eigentlichen aufgaben
übrig bleibt das wichtigste ist
vielleicht sich einfach nur bewusst zu
werden wie unglaublich schwer es ist
seine lebensgewohnheiten zu ändern so
dass man sich nicht immer wieder genau
die selben vorsätze macht die man dann
nicht einhalten kann
schön schlau habt ihr euch gute vorsätze
gemacht wenn ja würde mich sehr
interessieren was schreibe es in die
kommentare und wie immer schreibt uns
eure fragen und wenn ihr in den
kommentaren eine gute frage entdeckt
dann vergesst nicht diesen kommentar
einen daumen nach oben zu gehen damit
auch wieder sehen können was euch am
meisten interessiert ansonsten sehen uns
nächste woche wieder biss dann